It took just one week. One week was really
all the time that was needed for this man,
the President of the United States, to have
his first diplomatic crisis. So who was it
with? … Well you probably know the answer
to that question: It was with Mexico.
Donald Trump is… let’s say… “unique;”
he might be the only head of state capable
of defying a foreign president in public,
Peña Nieto in this case, by telling him on
Twitter that if he doesn't travel to Washington
with the idea of paying for the wall, he may
as well stay at home.
Needless to say, the visit never happened…
But don’t worry viewers, we’ve had enough
Trump talk too, the Donald is not going to
be the main character in this video. Today
we are going to focus on the NAFTA agreement
and, especially, on the relations between
Mexico and the USA.
NAFTA is a free trade agreement between the
US, Canada and Mexico. It was negotiated by
President George H. W. Bush in 1992 and it
was ratified and implemented by Bill Clinton
in 1994. This means NAFTA has been supported
both by Democrats and Republicans.
But let's take a look back and analyse which
events took place south of the Bravo River…
Let’s travel back in time to the1980s, a
time when Mexico was exhausted. The country’s
economic model was a worn out closed economy
and they were in state of crisis.
In fact, it was at that time that massive
emigration from Mexico to the US started to
happen. And it wasn't just any migratory wave…
it was one of the biggest migration waves
of all time.
And this happened in a time when American’s
weren't particularly liked in Mexico.
Since the war with the US from 1846-1848 when
Mexico lost more than half of its territory,
the popular sentiment in the country was the
the US is a great villain, the great enemy
that Mexico was facing.
By 1988 it was clear that Mexico’s closed
system was worn out and the President of Mexico,
who at that time was Carlos Salinas (a Harvard
graduate, by the way), decided to end this
and opted for opening Mexico to the world.
In his own words:
“The US is not the worst threat, but the
best opportunity"
And the leaders in North America decided not
to waste this chance. They got down to business
and decided to bet on extending to Mexico
a free trade agreement they had recently signed
with Canada. With this, NAFTA was born.
Since then, relations between the US and Mexico
have expanded a great deal.It is estimated
that trade between the two countries today
exceed half-a-trillion dollars.
Now, half-a-trillion (500 billion) dollars
is quite a hard number to get your head around.
In more relatable terms: each minute, more
than a million dollars-worth of products crosses
the borders of the US and Mexico.
Or, to put it in an international context,
trade between the US and Mexico is the equivalent
of the Chilean economy and is more than the
entire economy of Argentina.
The current American president, Donald Trump,
threatens this agreement, and has even considered
putting an end to it because, according to
him, it is the worst agreement that the US
has ever signed.
Now, that’s just what he says, the reality
is rather different. NAFTA has been, in general,
a gold-mine for the United States.
It has been said that whenever Trump has a
nightmare, it’s always the same thing: he
sees a Mexican stealing his wallet.
Anyway, I don't know if it is true (probably
not), but it would explain his obsession with
Mexico and also why whenever he thinks of
NAFTA he thinks of the American people getting
robbed.
But, don’t think that it is only the President
who has this opinion. Many defenders of protectionism
in the US state that Mexican and Canadian
workers are causing American jobs to disappear
because of free trade.
Specifically they claim that imports exceed
exports by almost $80 billion, and that’s
saying a lot!
But the reality is that that figures are about
as reliable as a chocolate teapot.
First, there are two goods that twist those
numbers which have nothing to do with NAFTA:
petrol and natural gas!
And this is really important because if we
don't consider these products, that trade
hole Trump is complaining pretty much disappears.
Alright, so maybe some of you are now wondering:
"hey, but Simon: Why wouldn't you consider
petrol and natural gas?" That’s a good question.
Well, that’s because unless Trump wants
to take the United States back to the Stone
Age, he will have to keep getting all the
petrol the country needs, whether that’s
from Mexico, Canada, Saudi Arabia, or anywhere
else…
But these fudged figures aren't the only ones,
the protectionist dreamers also fudge the
figures by not considering services businesses
– this includes things like the financial
sector, insurance, travelling, consulting,
the internet etc etc. But ignoring these is
like saying banks don’t make money and Google
doesn’t exist...
So, if we adjust these two fudged figures,
it turns out that the USA's result is not
a deficit but actually a surplus (that’s
for both Mexico as well as Canada). It’s
actually a surplus of more than $40 billion.
In any case: the American’s are really the
ones who are making off like bandits in this
trade relationship.
But alright, in Mexico it is a bit different
because, even correcting the numbers, the
US still gets the deficit in this relationship.
So the question is: what is the actual number?
Well, wait for it, approximately... drum-roll-please
[drum roll sound effect] … 0.25% of its
GDP.
Yes, It’s really not much… sorry to let
you down. In fact, the deficit is smaller
than the one they have with China, Japan,
or Germany.
Almost all American industries export to Mexico
more than they import, with the exception
of automobiles.
But let´s remember that most of the "Made
in Mexico" cars sold in the USA are from companies
of American origin, like Ford or General Motors.
So you can guess where the profits are going
to end up…
But there’s more: It is said that the main
reason for the companies moving their factories
to Mexico is because the wages are lower,
but that is only half true, and it certainly
isn’t the main reason.
What’s interesting about Mexico for car
companies is that Mexico has many more free
trade agreements with other countries than
the US, and this allows them to produce and
sell their cars in other markets like Brazil
or the European Union thus saving a lot of
money in tariffs – about $700 million a
year.
And where are the benefits of these operations
going to end up? Yep, once again, right back
in the United States of America.
Just like happens in casinos, the house always
wins.
So, thanks to Mexico, car companies in the
USA are more competitive and have more profits
while consumers in America can buy much cheaper
cars.
And because of this, Americans have more money
available to go to the cinema, to buy clothes,
to change their smartphones more often, and
take part in all that consumer spending we
so love. All making the economic wheels spin
faster and faster.
So, if now it seems that Mexico is important
to the USA, imagine the other way around…
Almost 80% of Mexican exports end up in their
Northern neighbour.
So it is no surprise that the threat of the
end of NAFTA has reminded many of the famous
quote attributed to Porfirio Díaz: "Poor
Mexico, so far from God and so near the USA".
NAFTA has been incredibly positive for Mexico.
As a quick example, do you know which is the
biggest employer in Mexico? Well, that’s
Walmart.
Unfortunately, this huge investment by US
companies hasn’t had the growth that was
expected in Mexico. Why? Well, for that, we
need to look for responsibility inside the
country.
The truth is that Mexican politicians haven’t
know how to take advantage of this fantastic
opportunity to make Mexico more modern and
competitive. But you know, bad politics equals
bad results.
However, does this all mean Mexico has to
kneel in front of Donald Trump? Certainly
not…
Donald Trump has threatened Mexico with high
tariffs on their products IF THEY REFUSE TO
PAY FOR THE WALL. To be specific, Trump´s
administration has threatened a 20% tariff
increase…
For starters, well this is illegal. There
are rules in the World Trade Organization
that prevent this from happening. One of these
rules is known as "the most favoured nation",
which means that no member of the WTO can
discriminate against any other.
In fact, the maximum tariff would have to
be limited to a 3% in case that NAFTA were
abolished. This would be a tax for consumers
and American companies and wouldn´t affect
trade between the two nations.
But even if the US (with the Congress approval)
were willing to ignore international law,
Mexico has enough resources to fight it and
try to stop this:
First, Mexico would be able to take advantage
of the influence of the multinational corporations
operating in Mexico which could stand to lose
billions of dollars.
And this is not just the influence of a few
rich men... We are talking about all these
companies’ workers and their shareholders,
as well as millions of individual savers throughout
the US.
And second: relations between Mexico and the
USA aren't just commercial: immigration, drug-trafficking,
terrorism are just another few aspects of
their relationship... If Trump attacks economically,
Mexico could fight back, for example, by letting
the US drown in drugs and immigration waves
from all countries across Latin America.
The fact is that the USA and Mexico need each
other more than it seems, and Mexico is not
in as weak of a position as Trump thinks.
Although Peña Nieto is unpredictable, it
does look like he understands this, and the
message from the government in Mexico is clear:
Let's talk about NAFTA, we will renegotiate
this treaty, but then other treaties are going
to be open to negotiation as well.
So, what do you think? Should Mexico defend
itself tooth and nail even with the risk of
triggering a trade war with its neighbour?
Or should the nation be patient, let things
go and look for a conciliatory solution? Let
us know in the comments below, we read them
all and try to reply when we can! Don’t
forget we put out brand new videos every Monday
and Thursday, so don’t forget to subscribe!
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.